Hello everyone and welcome back to the coverage of the Vita World Cup
2019 while things are heating up in the in the game for the finals
We also need to check up on the match Yu Yangyi versus Maxime Vachier-Lagrave
two of them the two of the classical games ended in a draw then two of the rapid games ended in a draw and
This is there a fourth rapid game the one with the shorter time format
Maxime won Game three of the rapid section and now young he has the white pieces
And he needs needs a win in order to equalize and go
Take this further into the tiebreaks. So without further ado. Let's check it out and see who claims the the third-place
Yu Youngyi opens the with d4 we have Knight to f6
c4 g6 and the Knight to c3 and of course the five add the Grunfeld defense is on the board Maxime yet again goes for
his famous weapon
C captures Knight captures and just e4 going into the main line Knight captures B captures Bishop to g7
with Queen to a4 check
Black needs to deal with this somehow and we have Knight to d7 and now Knight to f3 continuing development
Black does the same Maxim castles here and now Bishop to g5?
and c5 the usual idea
when playing the Grunfeld you want to attack white center with the C pawn with the bishop and and the force white to
deal with this
We have rock to d1 getting the rock out of this nasty diagonal also putting putting it on this very nice file
We have C captures on b4, C captures on d4 and now Knight back to f6 and here there is a game where this position
Was reached it was in the 2016 Women's Olympiad Elizabeth
Pyatt said this position against Maria Karolina Lujan and the that game ended in a draw now
But in the game Bishop to d3 was played here we have d5 and it is a new move in the position
But as you know Yu Youngyi really loves pushing pawns, so he's preparing e5
we have Bishop to d7 attacking Yu's Queen here on a4 and now Queen to b4 going after the b7 pawn and now
Queen to b6
Working out for Maxime  as if captures captures
Then he gets the very nice open file for his rook and on the other hand the Queen trade
Is avoided then white could be in some trouble as this king is still on a1 and the bishop still hasn't developed
So Yu here decides to trade with captures A captures and the now
e5 so that those are very far advanced pawns
But it's only good if it's good here Maxime goes Knight to g4. And now the question is: how do you defend the e5 pawn?
Well, this is what you had in mind. He plays east six here and
Well, it just seems like in every game between Yu and Maxime, Yu's D pawn and E pawn are just marching up
the board and okay maxime
Captures it it does seem to be a free pawn and now comes Bishop to c4 now
hoping it that if captures captures and you can also pick up this pawn as Bishop will capture with check but
Maxime finds a very nice solution . So he plays Bishop to a4 now forcing you to deal with the rook on d1
We have rock back to c1 and now even b5 pushing the bishop further back
Bishop to e2 and only now E captures on d5 and now Maxime is preparing e5 d4 and with this kind of pawn mass
In the center, he would just be winning
So the question is, can you grab the e7 pawn if you can it's great if he can't then after this pawn moves?
It's just gonna be an overwhelming
Position to deal with Maxime still has the bishop pair the semi open file for his a8 rook and well
It's hard to say, can you capture the pawn but?
You need the wind so he doesn't want to allow e5 he grabs it not with that
but with the Bishop Bishop captures on e7
We have worked e8 by Maxime attacking the bishop and now Bishop to g5
The problem for white is that his King is still on
E1 and you can't really castle as the bishop would be hanging here. So with b4
Clearing the b5 square for his light square bishop and now comes King to f1
You have to unpin if you don't want to allow this
But now comes something Maxime had planned and the white Bishop captures on e7 essentially doesn't work
so feel free to pause the video here and try to find the winning move for Maxime in this position while I give you a
couple of seconds
For those of you who were able to do it congratulations on being such an excellent exchange sacrificer
And for those who just want to enjoy the show, it's rook captures Ani, too
So it doesn't matter if the King unpinned the ideas it still applies
If you don't want to be down a piece, you have to capture the rook
So King captures on e2 and only now Bishop to b5 check
So what do you do here King to e1 and here Maxime just played Bishop the c3 check and it was in this position
on move 24 that Yu Yungyi resigned the game and it is Maxime Vachier-Lagrave who claims third place at the Fitty World Cup
2019 and with this he's also he will also be taken into consideration consideration as the wild-card for the Fitty
2020 candidates tournament if he doesn't qualify through the feeder Grand Prix, but you know, it's always good to have
more chances as
two years ago
he
He really got he
Didn't manage to qualify for the can determine and he almost qualified by rating almost qualified through the World Cup almost qualified
Through the Grand Prix. It was just a really bad luck for him
So very exciting to see that he's doing well now and of course a white resigned here as there is nothing more to do white
Is in check you can not go anywhere on the on the light squares
You could block Bishop b2 that doesn't work because of Rock to e8 check you're gonna go King d1 and now Bishop a4
Check you don't have a move. You have to give up the rock. But then black and choose does he want this Rock?
Does he want this Rock check? King
c1 you're just gonna grab this one for free this one falls next complete
Massacre here on the other hand if you don't block if you play something like King d1
It's even worse Knight captures f2 check King c2 Bishop d3
With check King b3 and now of course Rock to a3 is checkmate
very nice stuff and
Lastly but not leastly
If you want to give up give the exchange back with Rock captures on c3 just be captures on c3 and okay
You've given back the exchange
But black will have an easy when the Rock is coming down here you once you consolidate you're gonna start pushing your C pawn you
Have to connected passed pawns in the center of the board
while white still has problems getting his rook into the game completely winning for black so Yu of course knows this and
After Bishop to c3 check he resigns at the game
So very interesting stuff and a lot of you have been asking. How does the whole qualification for the candidates work?
well, it's a very complicated process but
Basically, it's a Giri who qualifies through rating and there's a lot of going on on that
You know a whole whole story as a Maxime. I think he would have to win 27 rating points on up until November
So he could qualify by rating even though he's higher rated and Giri
He he's a average over the past twelve months is lower than Giri's but then again there's this thing that where Giri
Had to play in the isle of man chess tournament and then he said that he will not play there, but there's no good
there's no good punishment for for not playing because Giri will now not play any classical games, so he doesn't lose ratings and
It says after you register for the tournament you cannot
You know abandon your registration and say I'm just not going to play the tournament you can only do it. They say if you've
Qualified for the candidates tournament through the World Cup where that's not the case with Giri
So it's interesting to see what will happen. Will he be fined in any way?
Will there be a punishment or will they just you know, look the other way, you know always exciting stuff in the chess world
But yeah, that's the game. I do hope you enjoyed it.
I would like to thank FL team and all been in Linus Ryan and Charles Schroeder for a contribution to my channel
Thank a lot. I really appreciate it as usual. You can check two of my previous videos here
Thank you for watching and I will see you soon
To continue in the coverage of the Vita World Cup checking up on your suggestions and so on
So thank you all I will see you soon and have an excellent rest of your day